Hi, so what we're going to actually cover
first is really, really important. We're
going to cover the differences between
retail traders and professional traders.
But we're going to start at Professional
Traders 101, which is essentially defining
what a professional trader actually is,
and what a successful professional trader
actually does. Now, this is really
important, and you should not
underestimate it. Simply because, from a
professional trader's perspective, I can
tell you uncategorically that retail
traders totally misinterpret and
misunderstand what professional traders
do. Now, this leads to a big
problem because essentially retail
traders, their objectives are really to
emulate what successful traders do, but do
it with their own money. Now, it's a
problem because it leads to retail traders
to make many, many, many mistakes and go
down the wrong path of trading. Now, once
you understand what a professional trader
actually
what a professional trader actually is,
and what a successful professional trader
does, then you can begin to emulate, with
your own money, what a professional trader
does. So, we're going to go over to the
stage now, and I want you to really focus
on your objectives here. Your objective,
as a retail trader, is to make money using
your own money.
and in the process, and in the process to
emulate successful professional traders,
therefore, we're going to start by
defining exactly what a professional
trader is, then we'll move on in the next
section, to what successful professional
traders do.
So, let's go over to the stage, and I'll
see you on the other side.
So, the first part we're going to do is
actually define what professional traders
do.
Question 1. What does a guy at an
investment bank do? A professional trader?
What does a guy at a hedge fund do?
They're quite different functions, quite
different roles.
What does it mean for the retail trader
who's trying to emulate them? And the
differences between professional traders
and retail traders?
So, professional traders at investment
banks. 90% of a trader's time at an
investment bank is actually spent being a
market maker.
And only 10% of their time is actually
spent trading the bank's money and using
that money in an attempt to make a profit.
So, when you look on CNBC, Bloomberg, on
the television, and you see the trading
floors with all the guys walking around
and lots of screens at their desks, what
are they actually doing?
Well, 90% of the time, they're just making
prices in the market to clients.
So, is that what we do as retail traders?
Who says yes?
Well, it's clearly not. We don't have any
clients. We don't care.
The objective here, like this gentleman
already outlined, is to just make money.
Using our own money to make money.
We've got no interest in market making.
But let's have a look at the business, how
it actually works.
The market making business is literally
the bread and butter of the bank.
And it's split into two categories,
really.
It's an agency business and a risk
business, okay?
What do we mean by an agency business?
You're not on risk to the client.
So, the agency business, literally, a guy
calls in from a pension fund or a hedge
fund and they want to buy an asset.
They give the bank the order to buy the
asset on their behalf.
And it's just executed in the market.
And a commission is charged.
And commissions are charged in basis
points.
And 100 basis points is 1%.
So, what's a typical commission these
days?
Anybody?
What do you think?
On an agency trade.
Who said five basis points?
Yeah, four or five basis points.
Around a decade ago, the industry standard
was about 20-25 for agency business.
So, all things being constant in terms of
volume in the markets, the agency business
is down 80% in the last decade.
That's one of the reasons why banks
struggle.
And this is totally risk-free stuff to the
bank.
The phone just rings.
A salesperson takes the order, puts it in
the system.
And it goes through, typically, into an
algorithm.
And the algorithm executes it
electronically.
So, there's very little human
intervention.
And that's pretty much 80% of all
market-making business.
So, what does that tell you in terms of
the time split of a trader at an
investment bank?
What does it tell you?
What was the number in terms of time?
They were spending 90% market-making year.
And 80% of its agency.
So, the vast majority of the time, they're
actually just sitting at computers
watching orders being executed in the
market.
And just supervising them.
That's the vast majority of what
professional traders at investment banks
do.
It's pretty boring.
But the perception is that it's totally
the opposite.
People think that trading floors are these
huge hives of activity with lots of noise
and everyone shouting at each other.
It's just completely the opposite now.
But you can walk onto the Goldman Sachs,
Morgan Stanley, Bank of America, Merrill
Lynch trading floor.
And it's quieter than this room.
That's what they're doing most of the
time.
So, two things.
Firstly, get it out of your head that a
trader's job is exciting.
It's not.
It's literally the opposite.
It's really, really boring.
And secondly, if you're a retail trader,
the vast majority of what guys at
investment banks do, if you're trying to
emulate them, you're not emulating what
they do the vast majority of the time.
Because your objective is to make money
using your own money, not execute client
orders through an algorithm.
So, 20% of the market making business is
on risk.
So, instead of a client calling into the
office, pension fund, hedge fund, and
giving a risk-free order to the trader,
which they just bung in an algorithm.
The phone rings, and a salesperson picks
it up, and the client asks for a price in
the asset.
And the market maker goes on risk to the
client.
What does that mean?
They take the other side.
So, an example here, buying $10 million of
Apple stock at $500.
So, 20,000 shares, what actually happens,
the trader is short on the other side.
So, they're short $10 million of Apple
stock at $500.
If they buy it back above $500, they lose.
So, what does that actually mean?
Well, it means the trading function in the
risk model is to be the gatekeeper of the
bank's balance sheet.
So, the trader uses the bank's balance
sheet to attract business into the
company.
So, if they lose a dollar on that, they
buy it back at $501, they're losing
$20,000.
Does that make sense?
Now, if they're trading, they're not
trading one stock at a time.
Typically, a professional trader in an
investment bank will be trading between 50
and 100 stocks at any one time.
And what that is known as in the industry
is a negative selection portfolio.
So, you end up with 50 to 100 positions in
stocks or the assets that you trade, which
you don't even want.
The reason why you're doing it is to bring
business into the firm.
So, the bank gets the commission.
And where do those commissions get tagged?
They get tagged on the sales desk.
So, the traders on the trading desk offer
the bank's balance sheet to the world as
liquidity.
And then pension funds and hedge funds
come in and use that balance sheet to
trade.
And then they get rewarded by doing big
trades on risk by getting nice, juicy,
free agency orders to say thank you next
week.
Thank you for the week before for going on
risk to me in a situation where you knew
you were probably going to lose money.
And the ability of the market maker is
really priced on their ability to keep the
commission.
And we call that a loss ratio or a
retention ratio.
So, if $100 million comes in in one year
and you manage to keep $80 million of it,
which is a bloody good performance, your
retention ratio is 80%.
Which means you're a shit-hot market
maker.
So, that's 80% of the time agency, 20%
risk.
But it's 90% of the time.
So, only 10% of it is spent actually doing
what's called, well the polar opposite,
trading proprietarily.
As in, everything that the bank does,
proprietary to doing business with
clients.
That's why it's called proprietary
trading.
And it's the polar opposite.
Because the traders are using the bank's
balance sheet to do the opposite of a
negative selection portfolio.
So, what they're trying to do is use the
bank's balance sheet to make back the $20
million that they lost doing business.
So, the vast majority of the time is spent
supervising algorithms.
10% spent managing a positive selection
portfolio.
And they're typically long short
portfolios.
So, they want to be longer stock.
They want to be shorter stock.
They build that portfolio and they run it.
And typically, it's a one to three month
time horizon.
And this is what a typical guy's business.
So, if you just walk up to a guy on a
trading desk at an investment bank.
And say, what do you trade?
The guy says, I'll trade the top 100 S&P
500 stocks for XYZ bank.
And this is what the business will
probably look like in a typical fiscal
year.
Commission generated 50 million.
With a retention ratio of 70%.
And then the same amount of commission
coming in.
Roughly speaking, exposure in the
proprietary trading account.
Trying to make 20%.
And then the net loss ratio.
So, you end up with a total revenue of 45
on a turnover of 50.
Which is a pretty good performance.
That's a decent year.
The bank then gives that trader a
discretionary bonus.
So, they just pull a number out of thin
air.
It's not fixed.
It's just made up.
So, when you sign your contract to go and
work for an investment bank.
Your contract literally says, your bonus
is at the discretion of the bank.
And you have your bonus meetings leading
into the day you'll get told.
And then you get called in and get told.
And that's the day that everybody in the
year looks forward to.
Or dreads.
Basic salary is paid.
Which is usually less than your bonus.
If you're getting paid a bonus less than
your basic salary.
You shouldn't be working in the investment
banking industry.
And then an overhead cost.
Because it cost the bank a million dollars
for you to sit there.
So, total profit attributed to a trader
might look something like that.
These days.
In my day it was double.
So, really what have we learned here?
Well, in emulating professional traders.
At an investment bank.
You're not really trying to emulate.
At all.
What the professional trader does as a
market maker.
Your objective as a retail trader.
To make money with your own money.
Is more aligned with their.
Positive selection portfolio.
So, 90% of everything they do.
Has got nothing to do with your interest.
Unless you want to go and do.
Unless you want to go and work for a bank.
And become one of the guys that supervises
electronic orders.
But most importantly.
Or one of the most important things.
You'll see that a trader in investment
bank has a basic salary.
I'll make a statement.
And never ever ever forget it.
Every single professional trader in the
world.
Has a basic salary.
Every professional trader.
If they don't.
They're being legged over.
By the company that's hired them.
And if they make no money in the
proprietary trading account.
They don't get a bonus.
If they make money they get a bonus.
We'll come back to this later.
The issue of a basic salary.
So, what does a professional trader at
hedge fund do?
First things first.
Protect the capital.
Of their investors.
By making money in markets that go up.
And markets that go down.
But professional traders at hedge funds.
Usually called PMs.
Portfolio managers.
Why?
Pretty obvious.
They manage portfolios.
They don't go home at night.
With no positions.
Walk in the next day.
Get massively longer markets.
And then close out of the market.
Sure.
That's right.
And then close out of the market.
And close out of the market.
It's no coincidence why.
There's so many of the world's top hedge
fund managers.
Are ex-Goldman Sachs.
Ex-Morgan Stanley.
They've all been prop traders at
investment banks in the past.
And then they've gone on.
To do the same function.
With outside investors money.
Not the bank's money.
The guys at investment banks.
Are utilising the bank's capital.
So essentially that's shareholders money.
With their public companies.
So let's go through some basics of a hedge
fund.
But why is it called a hedge fund?
Because they use strategies that hedge up
risk.
So they can make money when the market
goes up and down.
But how is it structured?
But it's just an investment vehicle.
For high net worth and institutions to
invest in.
And you have an onshore management
company.
And an offshore holding company.
And the management company charges.
A one to two percent management fee.
To manage the money.
And an annual performance fee.
On the money they make.
Using the capital.
In their positive selection portfolio.
But what's very interesting about hedge
funds.
Is that when they go and pitch high net
worth and institutions.
As part of their pitch.
And one of the conditions.
For that investors have.
To invest in the fund.
Is that in a given year.
On the performance fee.
At least half of the performance fee.
Must be reinvested.
In the fund.
No hedge fund.
Charges a performance fee.
So let's have a look at a typical hedge
fund structure, a hedge fund example of
what might
happen in a typical year. So let's say
they're holding $100 million of investor
money as
assets under management and they've got 50
positions, 25 long, 25 short. And they
have
a self-imposed position limit, so no
position can be bigger than 2% in the
portfolio. So
nothing can be over $2 million. That's a
very diverse hedge fund. They're not
taking a great
deal of risk. Let's say last year they
made a 20% return on a portfolio with
mid-teens
volatility. That's a good hedge fund. If
they're diverse that much, they make 20%
and
they get mid, and it's on mid-teens
volatility. They're doing really well.
They've had a good
year. They charge a 2% management fee
based on the AUM at the beginning of the
year. So
the onshore management company takes $2
million of fees and $4 million performance
in that
situation. But $2 million of that $4
million is reinvested.
So what happens? It's pretty obvious. They
don't get paid a performance fee if they
lose
money. They get the management fee. So
first of all, what does the management fee
actually
do? What's it for? Anyone take a guess?
Exactly. The onshore management fee goes
to pay for
all of the infrastructure of the fund,
including basic salaries of everybody in
the office. That's
the first thing. All professional traders
have a basic salary, and so do hedge fund
managers.
But what about the performance when they
have a bad year? They don't get paid. In a
good
year, what do they do? They reinvest their
money into the fund. So the fund grows. So
what
do retail traders have to do if they're
trying to emulate successful hedge fund
managers?
They don't reinvest their money. So when
they make money, they take more risk. When
they lose
money, they don't increase their exposure.
It's pretty obvious, no? So why do retail
traders
do the total opposite? Secure their
profits. Yeah. So they're taking their
money out of their
trading account. That's a typical
behavior. Yeah. The holy grail for a hedge
fund manager
is to grow the fund, let's say from 100
million in year one, to 5 billion in year
six. And a
standard industry metric is applied to
sell the hedge fund. There'll be a value
to the
funds because they've got 5 billion of
assets under management. Does anybody know
what it is?
The standard industry metric for asset
managers and hedge funds? It's one-tenth
of assets under
management. So they'll sell that fund for
500 million. And they'll have their own
money in
the fund the fund the whole time and be
increasing their holding the whole time.
So they grow that
from 100 to 5 billion and walk away with
500 million. That's a successful hedge
fund manager.
So you should really be taking a few
messages from this. You know, if your
objective here is to make
money, which it is, no one goes into the
market to lose money. We all go in with
the idea that we're
going to become superstars and make loads
of money. So the objective here is to make
money using our own
money. So out of this, retail traders
should take several really important
messages. Hedge fund managers
use their own money and accept outside
investor money. Investment bank traders
don't. So what does that
mean? For a retail trader, your objective
is a hell of a lot more aligned with that
of a hedge fund manager.
The prop function and hedge fund managers,
they both hold long, short, diverse
portfolios with a fairly
medium term to long term time horizon,
obviously, depending on what company you
work for and what the
investment mandate is. They both get paid
a basic salary.
That's really important. So many retail
traders think trading is for income. It
isn't.
People must have seen it before where you
get the message, you get the emails,
you can make $10,000 a month trading the
international Forex markets.
So people do it. They open a trading
account, 100 grand. In month one, they
make 10 grand.
They take out the 10 grand. They spend it.
In month two, they lose 10 grand.
Then they take 10 grand out and they're
left with 80 and they spend 10 grand.
So what are they doing? When they make
money, they're taking money out of their
trading account.
When they lose money, they're taking more
risk. They're doing the total opposite to
what professional traders do.
You should never, ever, ever, ever, as a
retail trader, take an income from your
trading account.
It's not an income strategy. If you want
an income strategy, buy a bunch of stocks
and hold them for
a decade that pay a 4% dividend yield. Go
and buy a flat and rent it out to
somebody.
That'll pay you an income. Go and buy a
government bond. That'll pay you a coupon.
Trading is not for income. Every
professional trader knows that. That's why
they charge a management fee,
so they can get paid a basic salary.
And the industry is very, very
competitive. It's so competitive in the
hedge fund industry,
people going and pitching high net worth
in institutions for a limited amount of
capital.
It's so competitive that all of them still
ask for a management fee.
So why do we think they do that? Because
they know that trading is not for income.
Their objective is to grow their account
to as big as possible so they can sell the
fund.
So they don't want to take any money out
of the fund. They want to reinvest it as
much as they can.
Because they want an exit for as big as
possible, as quickly as possible.
Does that make sense?
So hedge fund managers are literally doing
the total opposite.
to what most retail traders do.
When they make money, reinvest.
Lose money, don't increase your risk.
So let's go through some of the main
differences. We have touched on some of
them already.
Differences between professional traders
and retail traders.
So if you're going to compare yourself or
try to emulate the best and most
successful professional traders.
You've got to emulate their strategies.
And from a very basic level, we've been
through some of them.
You've got to have a basic salary doing
something else to begin with.
Otherwise, you're just not going to grow
your account.
Because you'll be forced to take an income
from your trading account.
And it'll be terminal.
You'll just go to zero.
Either very quickly or slowly.
But you will be at zero at some point if
you do that.
And the principle of taking more risk when
you make money and taking less risk when
you lose money.
From the ground up, that's pretty basic
stuff.
But millions of people get it wrong every
year.
And it's repeat and rinse.
Every year, same approach.
Go to zero.
Start again.
Put 10 grand in your trading account.
Lose it.
Go to zero.
Six months later, start again with another
10 grand.
Do it again.
No one ever learns.
But the problem is, is due to all the
misinformation and conflict of interest
that exists in the industry.
This is why people behave like that.
So we've touched on one of them already.
Which is pretty obvious.
What a professional trader actually does.
You'll get tons of people in the industry
who have got the conflict of interest.
Showing you or trying to convince you that
professional traders approach the markets
in a particular way.
When they actually don't.
And that person who's telling you that has
never been a professional trader.
So how would they know?
There's a lot of misinformation and the
misinformation is due to a conflict of
interest.
So what is the difference?
What are the approach differences?
So hedge fund manager, investment bank,
professional trader, with a positive
selection portfolio.
Long short portfolio, one to three months.
Retail trader, the approach is typically
directional day trading.
Around binary situations.
What's the approach to risk?
Diversity and risk management.
The job of the hedge fund manager and even
the guy at the investment bank in the prop
trading function.
Their job first and foremost is to protect
that money.
And then seek to grow it.
So by first protecting it, what's
required?
Real diversity and proper risk management.
All you'll hear talked about on a desk at
an investment bank or a hedge fund is the
risk.
What's the risk here?
Are you on top of your risk?
What can we make or lose in one day?
With the retail trader, risk is extremely
concentrated.
So concentrated, when a professional
trader looks at a retail trader's trading
book, they can't understand why somebody
would only have two or three or four
positions.
It's lunacy.
They look at it and they just can't
understand why.
So someone might be long the S&P 500,
might have a long Euro-US dollar position
and short a dollar-yen position.
But also you've got no diversity.
You're just going to be up or down on the
day and your book is out of control.
You can't control what's going to happen.
So professional traders will just never,
ever do that.
What's the approach to return?
Professional traders are seeking long-term
consistent returns.
We know that because the objective is of
the hedge fund managers to get AUM assets
under management.
No one's going to invest in the hedge fund
or that trader if they're up 10% one
month, down 10% the next month, and they
just never make money.
You want consistent returns, smoothed over
time, which show a strong track record.
And behaviour in good times and bad times
in the portfolio where people recognise
you do the right thing in good and bad
times.
So you show good behaviour in your track
record.
So when you make money, you know you're
making money and you increase your risk.
And when you lose money, you do the right
things to reduce risk.
And if you show that over a number of
years with smooth returns, you're going to
have a much easier job pitching somebody
for 100 million to invest in your hedge
fund than if you're just all over the
place.
Retail trader, polar opposite, a good
month up massively, a bad month, loses all
their money.
Or half the money.
What's the outcome?
For the professional trader, it's all
about capital preservation and growth.
Sell the fund or get higher fees or bigger
bonuses.
2% on 5 billion is a lot of money.
What's the outcome for a retail trader?
Just capital destruction.
Capital destruction.
Assets go to zero.
Try again next year.
Professional trader.
What's the approach to income?
Ensure your minimum standard of living by
making sure you have a basic salary.
Retail trader.
Working full or part time in a normal day
job.
But they trade for extra income.
Which means if you open your account with
$100,000.
Even if you're good, in 10 years time,
you'll still have $100,000.
Because you're taking a salary.
In terms of growth, professional traders
will add when winning.
And reduce risk when losing.
What happens to the retail trader?
Take income when winning.
And seek risk when losing.
So, taking more risk.
What's the result?
Hedge fund managers will grow their assets
under management.
Retail trader trading account goes to
zero.
Outcome, the same as before.
So, here's the differences on one page.
Expectations management.
All professional traders aim to get rich
slowly.
Compound returns.
All professional traders seek consistent,
smoothed, risk-adjusted returns
compounded.
So, let's do a bit of compound math.
If you open a trading account with 10,000
pounds in year one.
And you use that 10,000 pounds to enable
you to take 40,000 pounds worth of
exposure.
If you get a 25% return each year, so call
it 2% a month on average, smoothed over
time.
There will be months where you lose, but
if you make an average of 2% a month.
In what year does your account become a
million?
Anyone know?
Has anyone ever done it in a spreadsheet?
Worked it out?
The eighth wonder of the world,
compounding.
Einstein did actually call it the eighth
wonder of the world.
It's about two-thirds of the way through
year seven.
So, you can grow 10,000 pounds at 2% a
month on average.
To over a million by the end of year
seven.
If you just keep reinvesting and never
taking an income.
But one thing is guaranteed.
If you take an income of 2,000 pounds a
month, you'll still be at 10.
Or you'll be at zero.
So, you've got two choices.
You either do it that way, the
professional trade away, the real way.
Or you do it the retail trade away.
And just never, ever, ever become
wealthier.
I don't think we need to go over this one
again.
No income from trading.
Retail traders want to take income.
Professional traders don't.
They ensure their basic salaries.
So, they make sure they get their minimum
living standards.
From making a basic salary.
So, to recap, and we know what the
differences are.
The majority of retail traders just lose
money because they do the opposite of what
all successful professional traders do.
In all ways.
Approach, risk, income, everything.
Everything is the opposite.
Okay.
So, welcome back.
That was professional traders and retail
traders.
And I guess, what have we learnt here?
Well, I think what we've learnt here in
terms of what professional traders
actually are, is that there is a very big
misguided perception or misinterpretation
of what professional traders are and what
they actually do.
I think in the retail trading community,
we need to clarify quite a few things in
terms of the professional traders'
objectives.
Because essentially, as retail traders,
you're trading with your own money.
And you're trying to emulate the
successful professional traders and trying
to make money with your own money.
Well, it seems like we can forget about
guys at investment banks.
The only thing to take away from guys at
investment banks is that they have a basic
salary.
The rest of the stuff they do, it's just
not in the same objective as the retail
trader.
Investment banks are trading with the
bank's money when they're doing
proprietary trading, as in all business
within the bank that's proprietary to
doing business with clients.
The vast majority of the time, and we're
talking 80-90% of the time, of a
professional trader at an investment bank,
they are trading with clients, so either
on behalf of the client, or they're
trading on the other side of the client
and taking risk using the bank's money on
the other side.
Nothing a retail trader does is in any way
similar.
So, these guys, in terms of 80-90% of
their day-to-day activities, retail
traders, you just don't need to think
about it.
The only thing that they do which is
similar is proprietary trading, which is
using the bank's money to make back the
losses from doing client business.
In their approach, in terms of prop
trading, that's what we're interested in
because that approach is very similar to
hedge fund managers.
It's no coincidence that most hedge fund
managers originally start off at
investment banks.
The proprietary trading function of a guy
in the investment bank is very similar to
the approach of a hedge fund manager.
But remember one thing, the guy in the
investment bank, 80-90% of what they do is
irrelevant for retail traders.
And the second thing, they get a basic
salary.
Hedge fund managers different in that they
have their own money in the fund.
Very similar to retail traders in their
objectives.
Because a hedge fund manager wants to
create wealth, but doing it in a very
different way.
A very different way to the way retail
traders would expect.
Firstly, they're charging a management
fee.
So they put their own money in their fund.
And they accept outside investors' money.
And they charge a management fee.
Some would say the reason why they accept
outside investors' money is so they can
charge a management fee.
So they can get a basic salary.
The management fee pays for all of the
infrastructure and basic salaries of the
office and the people at the hedge fund.
So, typically, a management fee would be
1-2% on assets under management AUM.
And then, on top of that, they're charging
a performance fee.
Typically, a performance fee would be 20%
of any money made for outside investors.
So, what have we got here?
We've got a basic salary which protects
the downside wealth of the hedge fund
manager.
It protects their downside.
So, it protects the hedge fund manager
from becoming poorer.
What have we got on the upside?
We've got the performance fee where the
hedge fund manager charges the performance
fee, typically 20%,
to become wealthier.
Now, how do they actually become
wealthier?
Well, what they do is they have contracts
with their outside investors.
And, typically, their outside investors
will make the manager contract to putting
at least half
the performance fee back into the hedge
fund, back into the strategy.
So, what does that mean?
Well, let's go through an example where a
hedge fund manager charges 2% of
management fee and 20% performance fee.
And, let's say, for example, it's your
money.
Well, if you put in 100 and it becomes 120
in one year.
So, let's say that's 100 million US
dollars and the hedge fund manager makes
20 million dollars in one year.
Well, if the hedge fund manager came to
you and said, I'm going to charge you a
20% performance fee,
4 million dollars, and I'm going to take
all of that money and just not reinvest in
the fund.
Well, you're not going to be very happy.
You're not going to be happy because it
gives you the message that the hedge fund
manager
is not willing to invest in their own
strategy.
That defeats the whole purpose.
The whole purpose here is that everybody
becomes wealthier together
and that the hedge fund manager's winning
strategy is so good that outside investors
want to invest in it.
Therefore, if it's so good, why is the
person not investing in their own
strategy?
Well, it doesn't make any sense.
So, typically, what will happen is they'll
be contracted to invest at least half of
the performance fee back into the fund.
So, out of that 4 million dollars, 2
million dollars will be reinvested.
Now, what happens if the hedge fund
manager doesn't make money?
So, the 100 million stays at 100 million.
Well, it's pretty obvious.
There's no performance fee.
Therefore, there's no reinvestment of the
performance fee.
So, what do hedge fund managers do?
They invest in themselves and increase
their trading accounts.
Because a hedge fund, essentially, if you
look at it in that way, it is a trading
account.
They invest in themselves when they're
making money and they don't invest when
they're not making money.
And the objective is, obviously, to make
money every year.
But every year, if they're making money,
to increase their assets under management.
What does this mean for retail traders?
Simple.
You don't take income from your trading
account.
You grow your trading account over your
lifetime.
Until retirement.
Now, think of the opposite situation.
Where if you're a retail trader, and this
is a very typical situation in the retail
trading community.
The vast majority of retail traders are
under the impression that trading is, for
some reason, for income.
Whether it's, they're going to do it full
time.
Or, what most people do is, they try to
trade and they try to supplement their
salary by taking a monthly income from
their trading account.
So, let's think of this in round numbers
again.
Let's say you put $100,000 in your trading
account.
And you have the impression that you're
going to make $10,000 a month trading the
Forex markets.
And you're going to take out $10,000 a
month, to supplement your salary, doing
something else.
So, you open your account, and after month
one, you're up $10,000.
What's the next thing you do?
Well, you need to pay yourself $10,000.
So, you take $10,000 out of your account,
what happens, your capital is back to
$100,000.
Now, if you go and spend that $10,000,
you're no wealthier.
So, there's no point.
Now, what happens if you then, in month
two, lose $10,000, but you're relying on
your trading account to pay you a salary
of $10,000?
Well, that just means you're going to take
$10,000 out of your account.
You're going to go from $100,000 to
$80,000.
Now, to maintain the same levels of
exposure, you're going to have to take
more risk to get the same return that you
had previously.
So, all that you're doing is the opposite
of what a professional trader does.
A professional trader doesn't take money
out when they're winning, and doesn't put
money in when they're losing.
But they don't take more risk either.
So, what you're actually doing is the
opposite.
When you make $10,000, you're taking it
out as income.
And when you lose, you're taking income
again, which means you're taking more risk
to maintain the same levels of exposure.
Now, if you're going to invest in a hedge
fund, I'd bet if you were going to put
your life savings in a hedge fund, you
would want to see consistency of returns.
You would want to see diversity in risk
management.
You would want to see responsibility.
And the consistency that they get, the
consistency comes over a long period of
time.
Now, if you put your money in that fund,
what's probably the most important thing?
Out of everything, probably the most
important thing is that the manager
themselves invests when they're winning.
When they're actually making money, they
don't take it out of the fund.
They put it back in the fund.
That's not going to sit with you very well
if the hedge fund manager charges you a
performance fee and takes their money out.
It just means you're sponsoring the hedge
fund manager to become wealthier, but
they're not investing in their own
strategy to become even more wealthier.
So, it doesn't make any sense.
It defeats the whole purpose.
So, a couple of things here.
First, basic salaries.
Don't be under the impression that you're
going to, for some reason, leave your job.
You're going to trade with your own money
and you're going to take a salary from
your trading account.
Because the only thing that's going to
happen, if, on a monthly basis, you take
money out when you're winning and you take
more risk when you're losing,
the only thing that can happen over time
is that your trading account goes to zero.
Secondly, the approach.
The approach has to be one of consistency,
diversity of risk management and
reinvestment of your money when you're
winning.
And taking no further risk when you're
losing or not making money.
Now, this situation of going to zero,
let's discuss this a little bit further.
What happens if you're in this situation
where every time you make money, you take
money out of your trading account,
and every time you lose money, you take
more risk?
Well, you're going to zero over time.
It just depends how long.
What happens if you leverage this
situation?
So, we now borrow a million dollars to
reinvest in the same strategy.
But we use the $100,000 as collateral to
borrow the $1 million to invest in this
strategy.
Well, it just means your $100,000 used as
collateral to cover losses against the
million dollars is going to go to zero
quicker.
Because you're going to have to pay those
liabilities.
And this is what happens in every trading
account that we call a margin account.
Margin is just money that's deposited in
your trading account.
And it's used as collateral to enable you
to borrow through the brokerage company 10
times typically in stocks and indices and
100 times in forex.
And if you do that, all that's going to
happen if you leverage this strategy is
you're going to go to zero quicker.
It's the only thing that can happen.
You take money out when you're winning.
You take more risk when you're losing.
The outcome is terminal.
Your account tends towards zero and goes
towards zero quicker.
So, you just shouldn't do it.
And you'll end up getting what we call a
margin call where the broker literally
gives you a call, a telephone call, and
sends you an email and says you have to
put more money in your trading account to
cover the losses in your account.
If you don't do that, you're wiped out.
So, let's summarize here before we move
on.
If you're going to use your own money to
trade, be under no illusion, professional
traders all have basic salaries.
You should have a basic salary as well.
You should maintain this basic salary.
You should trade to begin with as a hobby.
When you get good at trading, at some
point in the future, it may become a
viable option.
That it becomes a profession.
But as it stands, if you're working,
you've got a basic salary, and you're not
a professional trader, you're a retail
trader, maintain your basic salary and
protect your downside wealth.
That's the first thing.
Secondly, your account, your capital.
Do not take income from your trading
account when you're winning.
Do not take more risk when you're losing.
You should view your trading account as an
asset in itself and the asset you're
aiming to increase the value of this asset
over your lifetime between now and
retirement or even the day you die.
That asset sits on your balance sheet as a
human being.
And the value of that asset is completely
linked to your ability as a trader.
So if you're good, you increase the value
of your account and you have an option to
put more money into your trading account
and keep increasing the size of your
account.
If you're bad, you don't reinvest in that
strategy.
You just try to get better and when you
get better, then you have the option to
invest more money.
It's very straightforward, but many, many
people make the mistake because of
misinformation in the market and in the
big bad world that professional traders
take income from their trading account.
Professional traders have concentrated
risk, they take big risks, they're running
around screaming at lots of people,
they've got hundreds of computer screens.
It just doesn't work like that at all.
In fact, most of the things that you
probably think a professional trader does,
they're probably the total opposite of
what you would expect in reality.
And in reality, from a professional
trader's perspective, I can tell you they
absolutely are the opposite of what you
would expect.
So, just take those things on board.
Make sure you know them.
Now that you know what a professional
trader does, you can move on to
understanding what successful professional
traders do.
As in, the guys who have got the same
objectives as us, the hedge fund managers
that trade with their own money, trying to
become wealthier, using their own money as
capital.
That's what we're going to move on to now
in video number two.
I'll see you in clip two.